i'm a terrible swimmer i'm really really
bad there are so many captivating scenes
in the harry potter series you'd be
surprised at which ones the cast
struggled with we're talking awkward
kissing scenes freezing cold water and
horrific painful onset injuries that
looks really painful
so painful
number one there's always a dready
kissing scene towards the end of the
trio's journey they defeat a horcrux in
the chamber of secrets emotionally
overwhelmed ron and hermione embrace and
kiss for the first time it was the most
horrible thing
though there are tons of fans who ship
the iconic duo emma watson and rupert
grint definitely weren't as into it not
that they don't think highly of each
other it's just that their relationship
is more like brother and sister in real
life it just felt like incest that's the
only way i can describe it
number two when grand theft dragging
goes wrong
when we first get into deathly hallows
part 2 harry ron and hermione break into
gringotts grab a horcrux and escape on
the back of a dragon obviously things
can never pan out that smoothly and they
soon have to jump off and dive into a
lake not only was the lake freezing cold
but the actors had to swim back to shore
and do it over and over again in an
interview with coming soon emma watson
shares a lot about the dreaded day
because we had to get changed as part of
the next scene we couldn't wear anything
underneath i was lucky i had my bottom
half with some thermals on but i was
like this must be a joke it was so cold
i think rupert thought at one point that
his heart had stopped beating he feels
more dangerous
number three it seems like anything with
water proves a major challenge in goblet
of fire there's a moment where the
participants have to dive into the water
and retrieve something of importance to
them the actors performed their own
stunts at a specifically built
state-of-the-art production tank at
leavesden studios one thing you might
not know about daniel radcliffe is that
he's actually a really terrible swimmer
but for most of these swim sequences
he's underwater for up to two hours at a
time you sort of have a mode just being
like i'll just keep smiling and laughing
yes and hopefully this will end soon
number four just burn the whole place
down
the most significant similarity between
rupert grint and his character ron is
that they both have a crippling fear of
spiders i hate spiders
that's why in the chamber of secrets
rupert was significantly underwhelmed to
face off against a giant horde of
spiders rupert shared with bbc that i
don't like spiders in real life even
rubber ones i get really scared of
though most of them were brought to life
with cgi there was a huge animatronic
model used for aragog the biggest spider
of the group like we said just burn it
all down
why spiders why couldn't we follow the
butterflies number five one of the most
glamorous yet difficult scenes for emma
watson this moment was huge for hermione
as neither ron nor harry thought to ask
her to the ball because they only see
her as their friend their sidekick but
when she walks down those stairs that's
when things change emma talks about the
immense pressure she was faced with
during the harry potter 20th anniversary
return to hogwarts mike newell coached
me to walk down the stairs in the dress
don't swing your arms
okay he gives me a million different
directions about how to walk down the
stairs of course i fell down the stairs
number six
speaking of falling the goblet of fire
was full of intense challenges and
stunts but this one in particular when
harry was faced with a hungarian
horntail had daniel radcliff hanging
from a wire 40 feet up in the air fell i
think 40 feet and quite very very fast
actually that was really really
terrifying and i'm not afraid to admit
that number seven we're talking feasts
of rotting food yeah not gonna lie this
one is kind of a bummer as the great
hall always looked like the most fun
place to have a meal but actually not so
much the first day was the best because
they would serve fresh food but then on
day 2 3 4 it was still the same food
warwick davis who plays professor
flitwick talks about it in an interview
with mirror the fourth day you could
smell the great hall before you got in
it the food was the same food and it had
quite an amazing smell
do you ever stop eating
i'm hungry
number eight not a very fun breakfast
club experience when harry returns to
hogwarts for his fifth year nobody
believes him about voldemort's return he
even gets made fun of by professor
umbridge which naturally results in
harry getting detention off screen
though imelda stanton who plays umbridge
had a lot more empathy than her
character she talks with entertainment
weekly about how guilty she felt after
shooting that scene
gosh we're all capable of great cruelty
it was a horrible horrible feeling
number nine another one that's cool to
look at but not so cool to be in in the
order of the phoenix harry and a bunch
of other hogwarts students decide to
blow off their usual studies and
practice spells in the room of
requirement apparently due to the number
of fires going on and how many people
were in the room it was pretty
unbearable to be in i got really
claustrophobic in it yeah and hot
because it's just like really hot
number 10 still reeling from this one so
we all know cedric gets hit by the
killing curse but what you may not know
is to simulate the power of the hit
robert pattinson had to go through quite
a bit of pain throughout each take he
opens up about it during an interview
with lifestyle if you're just being
pulled back the conventional way it
doesn't hurt too much because you're
just landing on your back but that one
they had to be like a coil i had to get
hit in my groin
number 11 fun to watch but not so fun to
shoot although we love seeing quidditch
matches on screen apparently all that
came with it was a sore butt and getting
hit in the face with quaffles in an
interview with belfast telegraph daniel
radcliffe says footage is right up there
with the least fun things i've done in
harry potter it does hurt quite a lot
and it's not something i would rush back
to number 12 this one is actually pretty
wild
while portraying her character bellatrix
lestrange bonham carter got a little two
method as she was torturing her co-star
matthew lewis who plays neville when
using her wand to poke and prod at his
ear matthew moved a little too close to
it and it ended up perforating his
eardrum it did cause internal bleeding
but he couldn't bear to admit it to her
at the time that was terrible i felt
really mortified number 13 we all go
through it being a teenage boy it's
pretty natural to want to impress girls
but for matthew lewis he found it to be
near impossible on set he talked to ew
about his internal teenage boy's
struggle they came up with the idea of
the false teeth and fat soup i had to
wear for several years i didn't mind it
until i was 14 or 15 and there were
girls on set i was a bit like why is it
always me
number 14 the cast went through a lot of
physical transformations over the years
one of the many reasons rupert can't go
back and revisit the harry potter series
is because he'd spend too much time
cringing at his awkward teenage years he
talks to teen vogue about his biggest
regret my hair in film 4 is one of my
biggest regrets we went through our
puberty on camera you kind of see it all
it's very cringy number 15 we don't
blame you on this one maggie one thing
maggie smith hated about filming any of
her scenes was waiting around wearing
professor mcgonagall's clothes she told
the evening standard i used to find the
most exhausting thing was wearing those
hats they're the heaviest things in the
world how can you just sit back and say
oh oh i thought that was absolutely
wonderful why would you want to do it
again i thought it was perfect never
from wardrobe malfunctions rotting food
and painful ear injuries the cast of
harry potter really went through the
ringer to give us this incredible series
which scene do you think was the most
difficult for them